it is a trend that has been plaguing
Southern Nevada and really other cities
all across the country and that's
catalytic converter thefts they've
increased by more than a thousand
percent in just the last three years
thanks for staying with us here at 4 30.
I'm Denise Valdez I'm Kirsten Joyce one
city fighting back with new rules that a
hopes will curb the trend eight news
now's Brian will explains what they're
doing in North Las Vegas
you can literally lay underneath a car
in less than two minutes you're cut a
cat out north Las Vegas has passed a new
ordinance going after catalytic
converter thieves so you don't have to
end up getting something that looks like
this which could cost you hundreds or
even up to a thousand dollars to get
fixed punishments consist of up to six
months in jail and up to a one thousand
dollar fine if you're in possession of
uh illegally impossession of a catalytic
converter
um the the ordinance depicts who is
illegally in possession versus who can
legally possess while it takes criminals
minutes to steal one off your vehicle
the Payday for them could be around 200
you could end up paying between 500 to 2
000 for a repair we see probably at
least one a month just here of someone
getting their cat stolen there are some
ways to protect yourself according to
North Las Vegas assistant police chief
Michael Harris it's one of the things
that we offer through our community
engagement division uh our engraving
tools you we could loan those out so
it's the citizen citizens can put their
personal information on them another
tactic is installing cages around your
catalytic converter you can find some
companies that have cages already made
for your car like the Prius they already
have that out if not you just gotta come
to any you know shop that can do a
little bit of fabrication and they can
make you one now in the unfortunate case
that you do become a victim of a
catalytic converter theft make sure you
report it to law enforcement and then
get your vehicle into a shop like this
one reporting near the strip Brian will
eight news now
this new ordinance will make it tougher
for criminals to sell or transfer
catalytic converters and allow for
prosecution to occur